[Music]
so if you're watching this you have
probably played an open-world game they
are a dime a dozen especially in recent
years but not many are focused solely on
sniping Aaron Sampson you recently
played sniper ghost Warrior 3 the
developers brought into the office so
you could try out a preview build and I
kind of want to pick your brain and see
how they might actually be bringing like
this hardcore sniper game into an open
world because 2 was not open-world
correct yeah 2 is a linear level
progression 3 goes into open role that
seems to be taking a lot of influences
from Far Cry 4 in my mind and I think
the team right now their challenge is
sort of build a sniping identity within
an open-world game because as you've
mentioned there's a lot of those lately
and one of the things that they keep
talking about in that regard is
exfiltration the idea that an open-world
is a better match for a sniping game
because to have the way that snipers
work in real life is there's just a
continuous thing they got to get in
there they got to sneak up on their
target they got to take out their target
and then they have to get out safely and
then in their mind getting out safely as
a new thing it's interesting because
when a dev starts talking about
exfiltration and an open-world game it
makes me a little bit skeptical just
because in an open-world game you
naturally have to leave an area anyway
right so it's not exactly a feature but
then I tried to do a like a loud run I
took the suppressor off my sniper rifle
and I just tried to shoot my way through
and I made the mistake of going into a
tower and sniping from the high ground
and I died pretty quickly what they said
was one of their military consultants
they had on the game was just sort of
fun pointing out the fact that as a
sniper you don't want to cage yourself
in a high ground because of that exact
situation so you don't necessarily want
to go to the highest point to start
shooting because once you get noticed
you're gonna have to escape right you
have to get out you have to plan your
next move ahead because this is all one
continuous story right yes one
continuous story that focuses on this
guy named John north and he's going back
modern-day Georgia to find his brother
who's been taken by some kind of
separatist movement maybe brainwash
that's one of the central questions it's
not like one map though there's like
three maps so there is a story
progression and you can go back and
forth like shadow of mordor style
between the maps is more like early
Metal Gear Solid games where if you are
discovered you're kind of screwed or
that you kind of are hinting it maybe
you do have a fighting chance once
you're discovered I mean you have any
other side arms you can use or just like
you know equipment that'll help you
escape you do have a suppressed pistol
and you do have suppressed assault
rifles
however the suppressors are designed to
break after a couple of rounds right so
the game clearly wants you to go loud
just to escape and it does have some of
those elements from Far Cry such as when
you're escaping their outpost that you
can run into if you haven't cleared
earlier that could get you in a lot of
trouble and also the bases can start
firing mortar rounds if you really aggro
it so you can basically get bombed out
of existence so the game definitely
pushes you into the stealth route we
have a drone just scout the area and
figure out who to take out when almost
like a puzzle
sniping game at times right and then you
kill out only if you have to to get out
what does the actual sniping feel like
from your demo does it feel good was it
difficult like I imagine that would be
if they're really going for like
hardcore realism so the difficulty level
I played on had a moderate level of
realism mostly dealing with range in
windage if you dial in the range wrong
then your windage is off and you have a
good chance of missing your target
there's also some other things they take
into account how far away from your
target are when it comes to sounds so
you can actually use an unsuppressed
sniper rifle if you're more than I think
the Deaf side like 150 like yards away
they might not hear the shot and also
the game takes into account shadow like
real-time shadows so there's different
times a day if you're hiding shadows and
making your shots you might not get
spotted as opposed to just standing in
broad daylight
so yeah the the level of sniping it's
not hardcore like I wish games like this
would go a little bit more into helping
me way back when the Xbox one got
introduced they showed us the capability
the
box one controllers to figure out the
sensitivity of how hard you're pulling
the trigger and like also it is for
rumble motors and I kind of wish these
hardcore sniping games go a little bit
more into you actually having to make
the steady pull on the trigger or the
shot goes off and maybe like every gun
kicks a little differently though have
we have yet to see that in a sniping
game I do want to touch a little more on
the overall structure and gameplay loop
of the game you mentioned there's like a
economy and crafting system is that so
you're going to be doing missions and
maybe taking out certain targets and
then is that feeding back into going to
the safe houses and upgrading your
weapons or can you did you see much that
during the demo yeah they're
collectibles throughout the world
they're mostly Peas question marks all
over the map and then as you go through
the missions you find crates and there's
a currency system in a crafting system
because it's a persistent world I'm
assuming I don't know 100% but I'm
assuming you could probably just run out
of useful bullets at a certain point so
you have to always be going back to your
base and making these bullets they also
said there's a couple of friendly towns
so I'm assuming there's a trading system
at play there so it sounds like you'll
be doing activities to make sure your
gear is proper and up to speed in
between other missions in the game
cool thanks so much Aaron that is sniper
ghost Warrior 3 that will release on
April 4th 2017 for PC Xbox one and ps4
we will be hearing more news in the
coming months about the multiplayer
aspects of the game so for that stay
tuned to games.com
Oh